[LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]
GABE WEISS: Welcome to
our talk, Building IoT
Applications on Google Cloud.
I almost said the wrong one.
I am Gabe Weiss.
I'm a developer
advocate for Google
on Google Cloud Platform,
specializing in IoT.
Also on stage with me,
we have Calum Barnes.
He's a product
manager on IoT Core.
We have Martin Varela--
sorry, I'm, like, losing
people's names already,
developer advocate on start ups.
We have Alicia Williams--
sorry, Rob Wormald next to her.
He is a developer programs
engineer on Angular.
And lastly, Alicia Williams.
She is a developer advocate
on G Suite and Google Cloud
Platform.
So given the range
of people, that
might give you an idea of what
we're talking about today.
So now you know who we are.
I want to know who you all are.
So how many developers,
operators, infrastructure?
People that are doing the
work, quick show of hands,
how many do I have on that?
Woo hoo.
Nice.
Welcome.
Thank you.
Who out there are
executives, C levels,
business decision makers?
And some of the same hands are
going up, so start ups, yeah?
All right, cool.
How many data scientists do
we have, any data scientists?
Good, oh, yeah, nice.
Everyone else, do
your arms work?
So now that we all know
who each others are,
application development.
There are a lot
of decisions that
need to be made before
you can start laying down
code for an application.
I don't want to fool you into
thinking that, yes, we're
going to be building an end
to end app today in the 45
minutes we've got.
But I don't want to fool
you into thinking that you
can actually do it on stage.
All of these decisions
that need to be made,
we made a lot of
them beforehand.
What I do want you to
walk away from this talk
with are three things.
One, understanding
what questions
you want to be asking
yourself about the app
that you're going
to be building.
What are the different
parts that are out there?
What do we have product wise
in Google Cloud Platform that
help you build these
IoT applications?
Two, it really is, from
a raw code standpoint,
easy to build these
end to end apps.
There's a lot of moving parts.
There's a lot of
products involved.
But the actual
implementation of each part
is actually really easy to do.
And we'll be showing
you some of that.
And thirdly, that what
you can put together
in this short amount of
time is immediately useful.
The data that you can get
from these simple applications
can immediately be
introspected, can be looked at,
can be used to get ROI
on whatever business
that you're doing.
What I don't want you to
take away from this talk
is that whatever
you put together
in that short amount of
time is production ready.
It's not.
Product managers, don't
let your eng teams tell you
that what they put together
in a day for an IoT app
is totally ready for release.
And eng teams, don't let your
product managers tell you
that hey, I saw at Google they
put together an app in an hour.
That's enough time, right?
It's not.
Don't let them tell
you that it is.
So what's the first thing
that you need in order
to build an application?
Does anyone have any ideas?
You can shout it out.
If you're shy, it's OK.
I'll still give you my answer.
But does anyone have an idea?
What do you need before you
can build an application?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GABE WEISS: An idea,
absolutely, first shot, nice--
so you need an idea.
You need to know what you're
building towards in order
to build an application.
I'm going to walk you
through what our idea is
and how it dictated some
of the technology choices
that we made in order to
build our application.
The question that
I wanted answered--
who up here, amongst us,
is the coolest onstage?
Who's the most nervous?
Who's anxious being on
stage in front of everyone?
So there's one really reliable
way to detect stress in humans.
It's a chemical called cortisol.
You can test for
it in your blood.
And its presence
and the amount of it
tells you empirically
how stressed out you are.
I asked the organizers,
and they did
tell me I'm not
allowed to create
a biohazard situation on stage.
So I couldn't do blood testing.
So the next step, what
about blood pressure?
So blood pressure,
how elevated it is,
will tell you how
stressed you are.
Let's think about a
blood pressure cuff.
It requires that you can
detect your heart rate,
and you have to be able to
apply and release pressure
in an even way around your arm.
It's totally doable with IoT,
but maybe a little ambitious
for a 50 minute session.
So I kind of got rid of that.
So our last option
that I fell back to
is this thing called
the vagal tone impulse.
This is your vagus nerve.
The vagus nerve is what
regulates your heart rate.
It's what keeps your heart
rate within normal amounts.
During times of extreme
stress, the vagal tone impulse
is suppressed, so that your
heart rate can skyrocket,
so that you can be ready
to do whatever you want.
The comment-- you've
probably heard about it--
is the fight or flight response.
So once you're in that
mode, your heart rate
can go up, even though you don't
have any physical need for it.
So for example,
if you're nervous,
and you want to tear
off stage and run away,
you'll get your body
flooded with blood
so that you can do that faster.
So why am I giving you
this biology lesson?
I could have just
said, hey, we want
to know who's nervous on
stage, and away we go.
The reality is, I'm
vamping a little bit.
I wanted to give my team a
little bit of a head start,
so that we can actually
show you, as we're
building, what we're doing.
So I needed to give them
a little bit of time.
Also, there's still a
monster line outside.
So I wanted to make
sure that everyone
could come in before I'm talking
about the technical stuff.
So architecture--
here's the architecture
in its entirety
for the application
we are building today.
We're going to be creating a
simple data driven application,
using the IoT devices that Calum
is building for us as we speak.
For each piece of
this architecture,
I'm going to talk
through the product
that we chose, the other options
that are available to you
in Google Cloud Platform for
that piece of the architecture,
and then show you a little
bit of the implementation
that we're working
on as we speak.
So first, let's chat about
this device that we're making.
It will be able to measure your
heart rate and temperature.
And between those
two data points,
we're going to be able to
tell who's really nervous up
on stage.
Heart rate, in
particular, is going
to be our primary indicator.
So hardware and IoT--
how do you pick what
hardware you want to use?
Once you pick your
hardware, how do you
pick what programming
language, what software you
want to use on that device?
There is a problem
for those of us
that are building out
these devices right now.
And the reality is, who
was alive in the '70s?
That's the first question.
OK, good.
There's at least some of us.
I don't feel too old yet.
So in the '70s, we
had VHS and Betamax.
Did anyone own a Betamax player?
Yes, yeah, me, too.
Next if you heard
about laser discs?
Anyone hear about laser discs?
Yeah, all right, so
laser discs and DVDs.
And now we've got
Blu-ray and HD.
Hopefully, most of the
room would know about that.
So it's the idea of standards.
Each of those
technologies eventually
resolved into a standard that
most of the market could adopt.
In IoT, we don't have
standards right now.
It is a complete Wild West.
You could pick any
hardware and any software,
and it would still work.
This is just a small
sampling of the options
that you've got up there today.
Sometimes an
environmental factor
will help you narrow
down this choice.
So if you're working on
the side of a mountain,
your options will slim down.
You've got
communication problems.
You've got power
consumption issues.
That can help dictate what
hardware that you're picking.
The reality is that for most
large scale IoT installations,
you're going to have custom
hardware that gets built.
You're going to have
a microcontroller
with custom sensors
that really defines
the minimum device that
you need to accomplish,
whatever the goal is.
Our only real requirement
is to read analog sensors.
Our heart rate and temperature
sensors are analog.
They're off the shelf.
So we needed something
that could speak analog.
We also want it
super easy to set up.
We've only got 45 minutes
to build the entire thing.
So I wanted to be sure
that whatever we picked
would be really easy to set up.
The Python libraries
have everything we need.
Everything that we need
to do this end to end,
Python has libraries for them.
And it was out of the box.
We wanted something
that could run Python.
So our device is an
Arduino, so that we
could read the analog
devices really easily,
connected over
serial to a Raspberry
Pi, which is super easy to
connect and runs Python.
Production, obviously,
for most IoT,
that's not what you're
going to end up using.
It's not cost effective.
But for our purposes, just
to highlight the technology,
it's going to work great.
So let's take a look, if
we could, at the device
that Calum's building.
Could we switch to
demo one, please?
What we're seeing here is we can
see the Arduino chip right here
on top of our device.
And inside this case
is the Raspberry Pi.
The two sensors that
we're seeing now
is the heart rate sensor,
which is on a little ear clip.
And then we've got the
temperature sensor,
this little probe guy.
So I'm going to have that
temperature sensor in my mouth.
And we'll see how
accurate a reading
we can get as I'm
trying to give a talk
with a sensor in my mouth.
So before we check
out the software
that Calum's got on
the device running,
can we switch back to
slides now, please.
I want to talk to us a little
bit about ingesting our data.
Yay.
So before we can
ingest data, there
is something I
want to talk about,
and it's going to be the
hill that I die upon for IoT.
And it's a question.
What does the S
in IoT stand for?
Security-- it's funny,
because there's no S in IoT.
You get that?
Ha ha.
So there's a couple
of anecdotes I
want to tell about security
that kind of highlights
why you should care.
A couple of years
ago, a bunch of you
may remember, that the whole
internet, large swaths of it
went down for hours.
It was something called
the Mirai botnet attack.
And what Mirai software did is
it scanned the whole internet
for unsecured IoT devices.
It found 11.3 million of them.
It launched a
massive botnet attack
against DYN, the domain
services for the whole internet.
And it took the internet
down for a bunch of hours.
So that's the macro view--
all of those devices
could take down something
like the internet for a while.
Micro view-- last year, there
was a single temperature sensor
in a fishtank in a casino.
And it was connected
to an internal machine
so it could regulate the
temperature of that fish tank.
And an enterprising
young Finnish hacker
found that temperature
sensor, hacked it,
got access to the
internal machine
and pulled out 10 gigabytes
of high roller data
from that casino.
They lost millions of
dollars and lost face
to all those high rollers.
So this is why you need
to care about security.
The macro view with the Mirai
botnet attack and the micro,
with this Finnish hacker
taking all of the casino data.
I could talk for a
long time about how
you can counter-measure
this, how
you can secure your devices.
I'm not going to because,
on Thursday at 10:20,
there is Security and IoT Talk.
It's being done by a colleague
and a partner of ours.
That is a really good talk.
So if you want to learn and go
into depth on security and IoT,
go to their talk, because
it's going to be really good.
For ingestion, then--
back to that-- this
is why I picked Cloud IoT
Core as our choice for that.
Cloud IoT Core is the Google
Cloud Platform gateway
for devices to send
their telemetry data up
into the Cloud.
It handles things like
device authorization,
that security piece
I'm talking about.
Management-- it allows you
to configure your devices
from the Cloud.
You can send messages
back down to your devices.
It allows you to have your
devices report their state.
So you can check the health
of your fleet from the Cloud
without having to talk
directly to your device.
It's a managed service.
It's just an endpoint
that you talk to.
So you configure your
devices to talk to a URL.
There's no client library.
So if space is an
issue, if you're
on a microcontroller
with only 200k of space,
it's at a premium.
You don't want to
have client libraries.
IoT Core lets you handle that.
All right.
So before I show you
the code that Calum
is writing on the
device, I want to talk
to you about what the other
options that you could do.
Instead of talking
to IoT Core, what
are some other possibilities
that you could do?
You can leave IoT
Core and talk directly
to the event queue system
that backs it, Cloud Pub/Sub.
So you could cut out IoT Core.
I left the management
block on here on purpose.
Because if you skip IoT
Core, what you're left with
is having to manage
your devices.
You have to authorize them.
You have to deal with them if
one of them gets compromised
and you have to shut it off.
You have to now manage all
of that yourself in software.
Another option-- you
could skip all of that
and talk directly
to your data store.
Now on top of having to
manage all your devices,
you also have this
problem where,
what if your right to
your data store fails?
Someone kicks a cable
or sunspots or just
a plain networking problem?
Now all of that retry code to
get your data into your data
warehouse, instead of already
having your data in the Cloud,
in something safe
like Pub/Sub, now you
have to redo it
from your device.
Which, for devices, network
is your battery killer.
If you have to keep running
network from your device,
that's going to run
you out of batteries,
and causes this
cascade of failure.
So if you skip all of this and
talking directly to data store,
your devices or an
edge machine is now
responsible for doing
all of that retry logic.
So again, this is why
we went with IoT Core.
It's the way to go.
So we're almost ready
to talk to that code.
No, I lied.
We actually are ready to
talk the code from Calum now.
So if now we could switch
to the demo one, awesome.
And Calum is actually going
to take us through the code
that he wrote on the device.
CALUM BARNES: Thanks, Gabe.
So what I've done, since we
only have 45 minutes here,
is basically copied
most of the code
from the IoT Core
Python tutorial
written by another great
dev advocate, Gus Glass.
And what that does for us is
make two things really easy--
connecting and
authenticating with IoT Core,
and then sending messages
to IoT Core over MQTT.
And those are the
messages that are
going to contain
the data we're going
to build our application with.
So you can see in this
Python sample that
comes straight from the website,
we have a Create Jot function.
If you go to that security talk
Gabe mentioned on Thursday,
you'll find out even more about
how IoT authentication works.
But we create a special
Jot authentication token
based on a private
key on the device.
And this function
makes it really,
really easy to generate that
and send it to IoT Core.
And then the rest of
what we have is basically
boilerplate Paho MQTT code to
connect to the IoT Core MQTT
front ends.
All I've added in here
in the last few minutes
is some configuration
information
about the specific
project that Martin set up
when we got started.
And then a little bit of code
to talk to the serial input
from the Arduino
and toggle to LED
when we get over some limits
that we'll talk about later.
So all of this has been
pretty easy to write,
because I was able to
leverage the samples that we
have on the IoT Core
documentation website.
GABE WEISS: Great.
CALUM BARNES: Thanks, Gabe.
GABE WEISS: Thanks, Calum.
So we've now covered
kind of the why and the
how of devices and ingestion
in the Cloud getting up there.
Next up, we need to
get all of that data
from Cloud Pub/Sub,
where IoT Core puts it,
into our data storage.
We've decided to use Google
Cloud Functions to do that.
Cloud Functions are
serverless methods.
They can be called with either
an HTTP GET or POST call
or triggered from something
that happens in Google Cloud
Platform.
For us, we're using
Pub/Sub as our trigger.
So any message that
comes into Cloud Pub/Sub
will fire off this function.
Since I know Martin's probably
already getting bored,
since he finished this
in the first two minutes,
we're going to cut
over to Martin,
and we're going to show some
of the code that he did.
So we need to switch
to demo two, please.
MARTIN VARELA: Yep, that's it.
GABE WEISS: Awesome.
MARTIN VARELA: Thank you, Gabe.
So I just finished
five minutes ago--
I didn't have that much time--
deploying this function that is
called telemetry to Firestore.
Again, as Gabe said,
what this is doing,
this function is subscribed
to Pub/Sub topic,
so that every time one of the
devices that we are building
sends telemetry to IoT Core,
that sends a pops up message
and triggers a new
execution or a new instance
of this function.
Let's take a look
at the code here.
As you can see, this is
written in JavaScript.
And it's running on a
Node.js V6 environment.
At the top, I'm just calling
and importing the library
that I'm using to
write to Firestore
and initializing the app.
Because we are running on
this managed environment,
we don't need to do
any authentication.
That's handled for us.
And then the about 20
lines that are next
is the output function.
The function expects
an event from Pub/Sub.
I will check if it has data.
Otherwise, I'm going
to throw an error.
Then I'm going to [? base ?]
64 decode the payload,
parse it into a
JavaScript object,
so it's easier to
[? run ?] the attributes.
And then this is where I
run right to the [? DV. ?]
How Firebase works, or
how Firestore works is
that it stores a
collection of documents.
And each document can have a
bunch of different attributes.
In this case, we're sending
the timestamp, temperature,
and BPM, as you can see here.
And this is the path to where
I want to write the documents.
And then it's just--
whether it fails or not, I'm
going to console.log it just
for reference.
And that's pretty much it.
GABE WEISS: Sweet.
Thanks, Martin.
So this is the glue that
joins our event messaging
system as the telemetry's
coming in to our warehouse.
Can we switch back to
slides again, please?
So let's chat a bit
about the other options,
if you didn't want to
use Cloud Functions.
And there's a
reason you might not
want to use Cloud Functions.
For IoT, there's really
three really good options
in Google Cloud
Platform for this--
Cloud Functions, Cloud
Dataflow, and Cloud Dataproc.
Cloud Functions I've
already covered.
They're serverless.
It's a low barrier to entry,
because it's JavaScript,
so it's easy to stand
up and get going.
And it fires once per
message coming in.
That once per message coming
in-- that's the catch.
That's the reason
you might not want
to be using Cloud Functions.
If you're managing a fleet
of a million devices,
and those million
devices are sending
a message once a
second, that's now
a million firings per second
of this Cloud Function.
Part of their cost is
number of invocations.
So if you've got a system that
has a very high throughput,
that's why you might
want to look at Cloud
Dataflow, and Dataproc.
So Cloud Dataflow and Dataproc
are both managed service.
They're very similar
in what they can do.
Dataflow is our managed service
for transforming incoming batch
for streaming data.
It can do pipeline development
with the Apache Beam SDK.
And it handles very
high throughput.
That's what it's designed to do.
Dataproc is very
similar to that.
It also handles a
very high throughput.
It does a lot of
the same transforms.
It's hosted Apache
Hadoop and Apache Spark.
So really, why would you
pick one versus the other
is the platform that
you're familiar with.
So how do when you should
use one versus the other?
The answer is, it
really depends.
If you're not doing anything
but shuttling data from point A
to point B, you're just taking
it from the event system
and pushing it into
your data store,
it really doesn't
matter that much.
They're both going to
perform really well for you.
The invocations per second
is what I'm talking about.
So if you've got
very high throughput,
that's where you would
want to switch over
to Dataflow or Dataproc.
For me, general rule
of thumb, always
prototype with Cloud Functions.
Get your entire
end to end working.
Find out what you don't know.
Get everything functional.
And then when the cost
starts to become an issue,
cut over to Dataflow
or Dataproc.
All right.
So we've got ingest.
We've got devices.
We've got pipeline.
Next up, we're onto storage.
Everyone still
doing OK out there?
Ah, so I know I'm throwing a lot
of stuff at you very quickly.
I wish I could tell you
it's going to get better.
It's not.
I'm going to continue to
throw a lot of stuff at you
very quickly.
Because next up is storage.
And there's a lot to cover.
So for our application,
we picked Cloud Firestore.
It's a NoSQL database.
It's very low latency
and low response time.
It's perfect for doing the
real time visualization that I
talked about at the beginning.
Because, built into
it in native mode,
it's got a push mechanism,
an update mechanism,
where anytime you get a data
change, it fires a callback.
It's one of the unique
pieces of Firestore
in our kind of storage
options, which is why
we've decided to pick it today.
It's also really
easy to stand up.
So what are some
options if you didn't
want to use Cloud Firestore?
We have a flowchart for that.
No need to memorize this.
It's actually on our website.
It's at cloud.google.com/storage
options.
Memorize that one.
So this flowchart
is not intended
to give you the be all, end
all option for your storage.
There's a lot of edge cases
that are little gotchas in here.
But this flowchart will
help you with things like,
is your data structured or not?
Are you doing analytics
or real time analysis?
Do you need mobile SDKs?
That's what this flowchart
will help you with.
Cost is the last piece.
The flowchart won't
help you with cost.
But it's so dependent on
your individual applications.
We have tools
online that you can
put in things like general
throughput, amount of storage
you need.
The online tools
will help guide you
through what your rough
monthly cost will be,
depending on the
storage that you pick.
So there's too many on
that flowchart for us
to go through all
of them in detail.
But I want to
highlight just a few.
And to speak to IoT, there's
usually two different things
with storage that you're
wanting to care about
for an IoT application.
There's a real time analysis.
If you're doing things
like fault detection
or automatic inference, you want
to get a low latency response
or you're doing really
heavy analytics.
So IoT often is just a vehicle
to get data into the Cloud
to run analysis on.
Those are the two things.
And so I put them
on this graph so
that I can put our different
products on it to give you
just a ballpark finger
in the wind what
the different
products are good at.
So first up, Firestore.
I've already pretty
much covered it.
It's very, very
good at real time.
And it's not the
worst in analytics,
but it is a NoSQL database.
If you're not familiar
with SQL versus NoSQL,
NoSQL's not the best at doing
really complicated queries.
Because you have to scan a
whole bunch of rows and then
parse for what you
want within it,
since it's unstructured data.
SQL is much better for
writing that kind of query,
where you can really
get out exactly what you
want in the query.
So that's why Firestore
is where it is.
Next, we have Cloud Bigtable.
Bigtable is the speediest of
our speedy NoSQL databases.
It's incredibly fast.
And it scales up to really
massive amounts of data.
Petabytes of data are not
a problem for Bigtable.
The reason it's so far on the
analytics left-hand side--
because it's terrible at it.
The way that it is
so fast is that it
is incredibly bare bones.
Anything that you want on
top of it, you have to build.
There's no tooling
built into it.
So it's kind of a blank
canvas NoSQL database.
We would never have
done it for today,
because there's way too much
tooling you'd have to build up.
Next up is Cloud Datastore.
It's much more of an out
of the box NoSQL solution.
It's got a bunch of
tooling on top of it.
It's got a very
well-developed querying API,
and it's easy to
understand and use.
In function, it's very
similar to Cloud Firestore.
The tipping point
for us with Firestore
is why it's a little bit
better in the real time-- is
that update mechanism,
that push mechanism.
We didn't want to have to
build something to do push
to a real time front end.
So that's why we picked
it over Datastore.
Next, we have Cloud
SQL, our SQL option.
It's hosted by SQL or Postgres.
If you need a SQL database,
this is the option for it.
It's very low latency.
It's better on the analytics
scale, because it's SQL.
So it can do more
complex queries.
There is a gotcha in SQL--
you should know about it--
which is SQL cannot
horizontally scale.
It can only vertically scale.
So if all of your data fits
happily on a single machine,
awesome.
Use Cloud SQL if all
of your data will.
Now for today, I could
have used Cloud SQL.
There's no way our
sensors today are going
to overwhelm a single box.
But I didn't want to
highlight a solution that,
for most IoT applications,
aren't going to be doable.
Most IoT is going to
produce enough data that it
would overwhelm SQL right away.
And lastly, way down on the
corner, we have BigQuery.
Does anyone know about
BigQuery already?
A bunch of you do.
If you don't, get familiar.
If you're doing any
kind of data analytics,
BigQuery is what
you want to use.
Hands down, no question
you should be using it.
And if you're not
doing analytics
as part of your IoT
application, I would ask you--
why are you not doing
analytics as part
of your IoT application?
Because it's data, and a lot of
it, and you can get really cool
stuff out of it.
So BigQuery is-- it's unique
in the offering in that you
use SQL queries against
a NoSQL back end.
And it's amazing, which
means for analytics,
it is the best of both worlds.
You can use SQL statements,
and it horizontally scales.
It also will scale up
to petabytes of data.
And you can run
queries performant
for the size against that data.
Now having said that,
it is performant,
but it's not real time.
I would never ever build
a real time application
on top of BigQuery, because
it will be terrible at it.
If I had more time
in the session today,
and in a perfect
world, you would
want something like this,
where that Cloud Function is
pulling your data out
of PubSub and putting it
into your real time analysis
data store, like Firestore.
You would also duplicate
the data over into your data
warehouse, like BigQuery.
That way, you really get
the best of both worlds
for the cost of some
storage, which is cheap.
You get the real time analysis.
You get all of the low
latency of Firestore.
And you get the power and
the analytics of BigQuery
behind it.
So I've talked a
little bit about
latency, real-time processing.
Something that I haven't
talked about yet,
which I can't, is
computing on the edge.
That's kind of all the
buzzword right now, right?
You want to compute on the edge.
Be on the edge.
I could spend an entire
talk discussing Cloud
versus the Edge versus
Hybrid versus Fog,
although Fog really
is just edge.
It's just another buzzword.
The whole talk is going
to take up all the time.
Broadly speaking, kind
of a finger in the wind,
storage-- do it in the Cloud.
If you need real time compute,
low latency, do it on the Edge.
You want to do data
visualization, probably
safe doing it in the Cloud.
Safety checks on a
nuclear power plant?
Please do it on the Edge.
Don't do it on the Cloud.
So we've covered all of
our headless stuff now.
We've gone from device
up into IoT Core.
IoT Core bridged
into Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Functions
pulling off a Pub/Sub,
dumping it into Firestore,
all of the no visual stuff.
So we still have not answered
my question of who's nervous?
So let's see if we can
answer those questions.
I could spend a really
long time talking
about all of the front end
possibilities for an IoT
application.
This is like the tiniest
of samples up there.
I do not have a mountain of time
to talk about front ends of all
of what your options are.
So I'm going to talk
about the two options
that we have picked.
So we could have
just one front end.
But I wanted to see
how many people we
could pack up on stage here.
I asked if we could do four.
They told me I didn't have
enough pedestals to do four.
So we settled on two.
It was kind of a
negotiation back and forth.
So my goals for showing
you front ends to an IoT
application are twofold.
I wanted to show you real time
visualization and time slice
visualization of
data, and I wanted
to show off the front end's
ability to modify metadata
around a device.
And I talked about
earlier, IoT Core
has the ability to send
messages back down to a device
and configure them.
And we're going to try that.
Hopefully, the
demo gods are kind.
So first, to highlight the
real time display piece,
I wanted to talk about Angular.
That's what we picked.
How many of you know
what Angular is?
Yeah!
All right, so Angular
is our batteries
included framework
for JavaScript.
It has components
to do everything
that you would need to do in a
web app-- routing, animation,
rendering, forms, iolate
[? end ?] support, integrated
testing.
All of those things you would
want to have in a web app,
we've got in Angular.
So at this point,
I think we're going
to try and get me
loaded up with a device.
I think I'm ready.
Rob, are you ready to
show off your piece?
All right, so normally
you wouldn't ever
do this in production.
We would have unit tests.
We would have integrated tests.
We wouldn't be using a device
that we just built on stage.
Here, we just pray to the
demo gods and see how it goes.
All right.
So I'm going to hold
this in this hand.
Then we're going to slide--
Can we switch to-- what do you
want, [INAUDIBLE]---- demo two?
And input three--
uh huh, uh huh.
OK.
So let's see.
I'm shaking like a leaf, but I
think I have decent connection.
All right.
So what we're
seeing on screen now
is the iteration of the devices.
So all right-- so
we clicked on--
Gabe's device?
Hey, where'd it go?
Where's my device?
There we go.
Hey, Alicia, could we change
my name to something snazzier?
Gabe's device is kind of boring.
[LAUGHTER]
I am now the
Destroyer of Worlds.
Thank you, Alicia.
OK.
So if we click into
that, and we're seeing,
now, these latest readings, we
might have some garbage here.
Because when the
heartbeat sensor
isn't attached to
a finger, it just
sends kind of random
noise on analog.
So it looks like we're kind
of starting to normalize
a little bit on device here.
I'm trying to make
sure that I've got it.
Yeah?
OK.
I want to highlight two
things that just happened.
So first, the Angular
app that's on stage now
is reading from
Firestore in real time.
Any of the sensors that are
getting pushed once a second up
into the Cloud are being--
yeah, I'm still going--
are being shown here.
So you see, you
know, my BPMs 107.
I'm excited.
And two, Alicia made a change
to my device in Firestore
on her front end.
And it was almost instantly
recognized in the Angular app
and updated live.
So Rob, I do like
what we've done here.
But it's going to be hard
to tell, side by side, who's
actually the most nervous.
Can we get all five
of us in a graph?
ROB WORMALD: [INAUDIBLE].
GABE WEISS: Sure, I
can give you a minute.
While he's doing that, I'm going
to talk about our second front
app with what Alicia's
been working on.
Can we switch to
Alicia's laptop?
So while we're doing this,
once we're hooked up--
Martin and Calum, you guys
are getting hooked up.
Rob, when you're done
with the graph, go ahead,
and you get hooked up, too.
Hopefully now we've
got Alicia's screen
that's going to come up soon.
So while we're getting
her set up here,
the second front
that we're doing
is going to be Google Sheets
G Suite backed by Apps Script.
So do we know about Apps Script?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
GABE WEISS: A couple do, good.
That's why I want
to do this talk,
so we can highlight
the fact that we've
got Apps Script going on.
So what see onscreen
now is her screen.
And it's showing the
metadata configuration page.
So this is where
she changed my name
over to that Destroyer
of Worlds value.
So I know a lot of you are
thinking, like, yeah, and?
She changed a value.
It's happening in real
time, and we just built it.
It's going from one front
end, through the Cloud,
and updating in a
second front end.
The next thing I want to
show off is the next tab--
is the ability to configure
our devices in some fashion.
And this is where we really
see how this is going to go.
So right now on our
devices we have a value
called the heartbeat threshold.
So if my heartbeat goes
above that threshold,
the LED that's on this
device is going to light up.
Right now, it's set to 999.
Because we knew that when
the things aren't connected,
they send really high values.
And we didn't want to
accidentally go off early.
So now, let's go ahead
and set the threshold down
to 120, which both--
I should be able to hit and I
shouldn't hit at the moment.
So what I'm going
to try and do here
is see if I can get
it to trigger and get
this light to go on.
Hang in there.
[MUSIC - ELTON JOHN, "I'M STILL
STANDING"]
I am really out of shape!
All right!
So my heart-- I love the music.
[LAUGHS] I love the
music choice, guys.
All right.
So now we get to
play the game of how
long does it take Gabe's heart
rate to go back below 120--
probably a while.
So how this works
from Sheets-- we've
got a single cell that, when she
enters the threshold into it,
it iterates over
all of our devices
and fires off to
another Cloud Function.
It's a second called
function that Martin wrote.
And all it does is it calls
the-- shh-- the IoT Admin SDK
and sends that configuration
message back down to all
of our devices to update them.
Yes, I know.
I'm out of shape.
So the App Script
is calling HTTP
to call into that
second Cloud Function.
So it's not a trigger.
It's actually using
that first method
that I talked about with
the Cloud Functions.
The last piece that I
wanted to show off--
and we'll switch to
this, yeah, there we go--
is this is the time slice
data I was talking about.
So she is fetching the data
from the last 60 seconds or so.
So that big jaggy spike, that's
me running around the room
because ouch.
So with Sheets, you get up
to two million cells of data,
so what sheets is
really good at-- pulling
in large amounts of data.
So the graphing is going to
be similar to the Angular,
but I wanted to highlight.
It's the time slice, not the
real time that the Angular is.
So that's what we
want to highlight
for Sheets is that you're
looking at historical data,
not live.
Down below now is-- we've got
some conditional formatting.
So any time my heart rate
is above the set threshold,
it's being conditionally
formatted in that red.
So it's a quick way to get
just a quick and dirty look
at your data by doing some
analysis in semi-real time
so that you can see
what's happening.
So now I would like to go
through the Apps Script code,
if Alicia would be so kind.
ALICIA WILLIAMS: Sure.
So I think some of
you raised your hands.
But for those of
you that don't know,
App Script is a scripting
language based on JavaScript
with a bunch of
enhancements for G Suite
to be able to automate between
different Google products
and services.
So the first line of
code I want to show you
is just where I query Firestore.
So I'm using a
library that connects
App Script to Firestore.
And I'm querying for
a specific device.
I had Gabe's device
up there, the most
recent 60 measurements.
So then I'm taking that
returned list of measurements,
and I'm appending a new
row to the spreadsheet
for each measurement.
And kind of in between
there, I wanted
to know what time slice
it really represented,
because they are sent
about once a second.
But I am pulling the
first and last measurement
and just notating that
start and stop time.
And then finally, I'm adding
some conditional formatting
down here, creating a
conditional formatting rule.
So that any BPM value
over the current threshold
is made into a
background color of red.
GABE WEISS: Awesome.
Thank you, Alicia.
So now we've seen how
Apps Script does it,
pulling and showing the data.
Rob, talk to me.
How are we doing on graphs?
ROB WORMALD: Good to go.
GABE WEISS: All right.
So let's switch
back over to Rob.
And we will see, look, it's
our heart rates, all on screen.
So each of us has our own color.
And now I want to know--
Alicia, go ahead and get
hooked up to your device.
So she's in yellow.
That's that squiggly,
way up high.
That's the garbage data
that I was talking about.
So once she gets
properly hooked,
and it's already dipping down.
So what color was I?
I was blue.
I want to be the coolest.
I'm not the coolest.
Wow, Alicia, are
you still alive?
[LAUGHTER]
I'm blue.
I get to be the coolest
cucumber on stage.
Check that out.
We're all pretty close though.
So the question
has been answered.
I get to be--
and I'm out of shape.
I just ran around the room.
What's wrong with you people?
So Rob, now that
we've kind of seen it,
let's go into to your code.
And so we've seen Apps
Script do the data pulling.
Now I want to show
off the Angular
app doing the data pulling.
So go ahead, Rob.
ROB WORMALD: OK.
Switch over to my editor.
So I'm using Angular.
And obviously, I used the
Angular CLI to go ahead
and scaffold a
project, so it set up
tooling and building and
all that stuff that's
really hard about JavaScript.
I started-- the first
thing we looked at
was our devices screen.
And that's just a
couple of screens.
So I've got a very
simple device list
component, a little bit of HTML
with some Angular bindings.
We're just iterating
over our devices
and rendering some data.
One of the nice
things about Angular
is that we have a really,
really good relationship
with Firebase.
So we have a really nice
built in Firebase Angular
library, Angular Firestore.
And so it takes one line of
code to talk to Firestore,
extract that data,
and then I get
a real time display of that.
We go a little more in depth
into our detailed view.
You can see we're
doing the same thing.
We're just using our built
in Angular Fire service.
We are just extracting
data, getting
some routing parameters,
and just streaming
the last measurements
off of the device.
So that's kind of basic
Angular templating.
That works pretty simply.
For the pulse graph, because
that's a lot more complicated,
we're using D-3, which
is an awesome graphing
library that's open source.
Again, we're just
talking to Firebase,
getting that device
data coming out.
I won't bore you
with all the math
that we're going on in here.
But basically, we're taking
the BPM and the time stamp
and scaling them so
they fit in the screen.
And then, just rendering
a line across the screen.
So, there you go.
GABE WEISS: Sweet.
Thank you, Rob.
So let's go back to slides.
Yep.
All right.
So to recap, since
the keynote went
a little long, so I'm
trying to wrap us up so
we get us all back on schedule.
We built an entire app on stage
in front of you in 35 minutes.
We went from custom devices--
[INAUDIBLE],, really--
custom devices
up and through IoT Core.
Bridged into Cloud,
Cloud Pub/Sub,
Cloud Functions to pull from
Pub/Sub into Cloud Firestore.
Firestore firing
real time updates
to power our Angular app.
Google Sheets powered
by Apps Script
to show us time slice
data, configure our devices
with an LED that will
not shut off for me.
What else did we do-- and
it configured metadata
in Firestore as well.
That is our end to end
simple data application
all the way through.
Thank you, team, for
making all that happen.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]